it's 40-year-old rich hill on the mound
making his fourth start
of course his first against the white
sox this year surgically repaired
breaking ball popped up right side
and it is a rise with the catch one away
knocked down by hill time to recover and
just barely got him
there's the curve and it struck him out
so good first inning for rich hill
26 year old lucas giolito looking for 27
outs once again after his first career
no hitter
right hand side ta is there to collect
out number one
change-up and polanco was looking for
something else
yep fastball struck him out oh what a
fun chess match we got going on with
lucas and the twins
let's hit to center cave coming over
making a diving catch in center field
jake cave ends the inning and saves a
run
with a great diving catch
driven to right field to base it rosario
around second he's digging for third the
ball gets away from
angle rosario's going to be held at 30
went into a slide
and ceno will gain second base yeah i
don't know if he picked up
tony diaz quick enough and the twins
have second and third nobody out
and here comes luis at eyes driven a
left center field slicing away from
robert and down for a hit
rosario will score sono will be held and
the twins take the first lead
on an arise single and now here is
marwin infield playing back
ground ball right side a run will score
and the ball thrown
into left field on his way to third as a
rise he'll be waved around
and gonzalez goes to second
some slip shot defense by the white sox
and the twins have three up on the board
and now miguel sanello is single to
right his first time up
a high blast left center field
and that ball is gone a home run for
miguel ceno
number seven on the year and it's four
to nothing
three walks to start the fourth inning
and they're loaded up for danny mendick
the pitch a
little jam shot that's going to be
caught dropped by a rise
they're going to say it's not a catch
steps on second throws back to first and
he's going to be
out there and this is a
clown show right now as the umpires
don't know what to do
they're going to call time-out that's on
outcall and i saw a safe call both on
james mccann that cannot possibly be
somebody's out the umpires are still
talking this over and now they're going
to new york i mean this is a judgment
call on infield fly and is it high
enough certainly is a question
arise drops the ball well if it's
infield fly it's really easy because
everybody then stays at their back
there's an out safe at first meaning
mendix safe there
mccann is safe at second so yeah they're
reloaded
just with different runners and there's
one out
on the ground and through base hit there
it is
one run home here comes the second adam
angle a two run
single and the lead split in half so
this will be the second trip to the
mound and hill's going to come out
had a hard time throwing strikes and
he's got to come out here still taken
out early much
to his disgust not a happy camper
three and two two on two out
jose in the air right center ties the
ball game
a ricochet off the wall and the socks
kept wrapping on the door and jose
rims it open
on the ground madrigal smothers it picks
it up and got it out
nick with good range there for out
number two and now
cenote is second base with two gone
instead of two on one outs
so the go ahead run now at second base
driving a base hit sono around third
he's being waved in
mazzara throwing to the plate cut off by
abreu
and cave does come through with an rbi
hit
that'll bring up luis robert 5'4 twins
there was a hanging breaking ball and
now
it adorns luis roberts home run tree
and louise robert is in double digits
with his home runs
he's got 10 but more importantly it's a
5-5 game here in the 7.
and now the young man who homered to tie
the ball game
in the seventh the solo shot deep to
center field
two on one out for robert
line drive left field toward the corner
that is a fair ball
up and over the wall the sox will take
one run
sanchez scores welcome back yolmer
six five sox still going
luis robert is becoming a man before our
very eyes
fall in two strikes zara slings it to
right field
that's a base hit mccann scores robert
on his heels
luis is in it is eight five
socks and 20 20 is different in
so many ways sox fans
right side on the line mazara gallops in
to a white sox first place control